what is meant by words and phrases so i
think it's appropriate for us to sort of
figure out what that phrase cancel
culture means
is it new or is it something that's been
around for a long time and we just
renamed it
who gets to decide who or what is
canceled
it was the summer before i started the
ninth grade when the movie greece came
out you may remember that movie olivia
newton-john
and john travolta so my mom decided she
would take my three sisters and me to
see the movie
and we made it about 30 minutes into the
movie when my mom leaned over and said
we're leaving get your sisters we're
leaving
leaving you got to be kidding me olivia
knew john hasn't even put on her black
leather outfit yet you cannot be serious
but my mom was serious she was very
serious
my entire school was in that movie
theater
that day it was so embarrassing
i'm barely able to talk about it today
my mom grabbing her four children
and walking up my mom cancelled
the rest of that movie for me and she
was not the only parent i had who
engaged in cultural cancellation
my three sisters and i could not watch
happy days we could not watch gilligan's
island or sesame street
so you can forget about dallas or
dynasty or flamingo road
was that the cancel culture or was that
my parents deciding they wanted to
control what their children were exposed
to
and once i got married i actually came
too long for my parents rules on tv
they were nothing compared to my wife's
rules
she can hear a bad word through three
walls and a mute button
i had to check into a hotel to watch
true detective
and game of thrones she still doesn't
know i watched that
well i guess now she does is that the
cancel culture
i think it's a lady wanting to fill her
mind and spirit with good things with
positive things
if you don't like something on tv or in
entertainment you have the right not to
watch it
the question is do you have the right to
make sure no one
else can watch it either or hear it or
see it
or read it i think what frustrates many
of us
is the inconsistency with these new
societal rules
a professional golfer loses a
sponsorship for a word he uttered to
himself
but if you flip the station to another
show or another movie
you will hear people mock religion you
will hear god's name taken in vain
you will hear words that would get your
tongue cut out in my mother's house
and there's no consequence you take
jesus's name in vain and nothing happens
you utter another word and you lose your
job
i think what people want is some sense
of fairness and consistency
you know the first amendment says
congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of speech that
relates to congress to government
it does not relate to how we interact
with each other
we can set those rules too but they must
be fair
and they must be evenly applied freedom
is hard sometimes
your freedoms may offend me and vice
versa
freedom works best i think when it is
tempered with grace
with understanding people make mistakes
with applying the same rules to your own
words
that you apply to other people's words
our framers protected certain freedoms
for us but they were
also very concerned with the right of
those and the minority
they were concerned that the majority
would silence
or cancel if you will the minority
freedom grace education understanding
i think we could all benefit from the
proper balance of those ideals
how we treat the minority matters
because they may not be in the minority
forever
most of all i hope we can apply the same
standard of fairness to others
that we want applied to us
joining me now former congresswoman from
the great state of hawaii tulsi gabbard
hey tulsi how are you
aloha my friend it's good to talk to you
as always
likewise all right i used to turn to you
when we were serving together for
guidance
tell me what the castle culture is and
why we should be concerned with it
well you you rightly started this
conversation talking about
about freedom when you look at the
foundation of our democracy it is
based on this ideal this principle of
freedom freedom
of speech freedom for for every single
one of us to be able to share
our ideas and debate them to argue them
to agree or to disagree
uh to to pick and choose in this
marketplace of ideas those that we deem
to be right or wrong to be superior or
inferior and
and even for those ideas that may be
misleading or dangerous
that in this free marketplace we have
the right to then defeat
those ideas with with superior ones
and others have have the freedom to
choose choose what they want to believe
or not to believe or what they want to
adhere to so when you look at this
question what is cancel culture cancel
culture
is the opposite of this it is exactly
the opposite
of this foundational principle of our
democracy it means that
in a canceled culture you have some
people
who believe that they are special that
they are superior
that they have the power uh to be able
to shut down those who
have ideas and views that are different
who who may
follow a path that they deem to be the
wrong path and will therefore say nope
we're going to place obstacles in front
of you
we're going to silence certain voices so
that
only those who agree with us and the
path that we deem to be right is the one
that is before you to choose
and and the issue with this there's a
few issues but the main issue with this
is when you look at our rights and
freedoms
and our ability to to debate them and
respectfully come out the other end
agreeing or disagreeing as you and i
have
over the years it's based on the fact
that we are all children of god
and recognizing that we then treat each
other with respect
and respect this freedom that we have so
let's look down the path and say okay
well where does this cancel culture lead
us you see the
final expression of cancer culture in
islamist
terrorist groups like isis and al-qaeda
who who who uh basically go and behead
those who are in they deem to be
infidels or or heretics
in order to silence them in order to
protect others from being misled by
by those heretical ideas in the eyes of
an
isis or al-qaeda and so when we look at
cancel culture here at home
we see those efforts
to cancel or silence those
that um they don't want
the people to hear from those who may
offer a different
idea than the one that those in power
want
people uh to see or to hear or to be
exposed to and and so this is
when we look at the foundations of our
democracy this is
the danger of where this path leads us
unless we as individuals stand up
against it and and that's the la that's
the final point i want to make on this
is
what can we do because i get asked this
a lot what can we do
to stand up against this cancel culture
this fear-mongering this bullying that
if you don't
adhere to this path that those in power
say is the right one
then you're at risk of losing your job
you are at risk of losing family or
friends or being unpopular or losing
likes on social media
this this requires us to ask the
question of ourselves
uh who are we trying to please and this
is something for me
at a really young age i i recognize that
life is
short uh death can come at any time and
i was happiest and i'm happiest when
trying to live my life to be pleasing to
god
to my best friend and so as i've gone
through my life
and especially in politics the media is
coming at you with attacks political
opponents social media
i have always found that peace and that
strength
uh in going within and knowing you've
been great tulsa